si nous voulons diminuer le nombre de
parlementaires de députés et de
sénateurs et que ça se voit dans le
quinquennat
alors il n'y a pas d'autre solution que
de voter un texte très rapidement pour
dire qu aux prochaines législatives de
2022 y aura moins une parlementaire
parce que ça ne peut pas se faire pour
les législatives dans un mois et pour
les sénatoriales n'y a pas d'autre
solution que de reporter les
sénatoriales de 2007 à 2010 huit ans est
une bonne solution pour vous oui j'y
suis très favorable j'ai d'ailleurs un
peu travaillé sur le sujet afin de
préparer ce texte de loi pour un d'une
diminution générale de tous les
sénateurs en 2021 est comme ça ce serait
dans ce quinquennat que le nombre de
parlementaires auraient diminué c'est un
engagement du président mais c'est un
engagement qui avaient tous les
candidats à la présidentielle et moi je
pense qu'il faut le mettre en
application